we're almost there I have some I should
plug this in I have some funky
technology stuff plans but it sort of
depends on how quickly you work and
whether we'll get there or not sir
question mark let's see how we go before
we get to the final comic section in
order to make sure when we get there
rather than uh you get there it's
likewise as cool you want to try to
understand it I have two divergent off
to the side to think about this then
you'll be able come home sooner I
thought let's revise this you met this
idea before I it'll seem a bit old a bit
quaint like why are we doing this what
does have to do with anything it's uh
when we get to this being able to
interpret this quickly and effectively
be very very helpful to us okay so
here's the question I want to pose to
you you've been studying functions and
relations for a long time now like good
for five years okay and many of the ones
that you've studied they exist
get ready this is not English but it's
gonna be more concise they exist for all
real values of x that i read that that
upside down a it means or it's it's an
upside down a because it's a 4x all of
all the x's that belong to or are
elements of the real number set so let
me read it again many functions and
relations that you studied overshoes
they exist for ordinal values of x give
me an example y equals x y equals x
squared i think i heard another one
you can go on for a while couldn't you
um but they can old do they okay
sometimes a function or relation does
not exist for those days and we have
what's called we give it a name we say
you know it doesn't exist there so it
has a start of our little string
it's we have a domain registration today
domain restrictions come up in a whole
bunch other functions now I could just
list these out for you but I thought
it'd be a little more interesting for
you let's see if we induce individuals
gonna make you do it in pairs but I
think that might be too easy if you're
paired up to two brains I think you've
ever get all them too quickly I want you
to individually think of how many
functions and relations do you know that
have domain restrictions now obviously
let's have a look at these three right
these don't have domain restrictions but
I would kind of love all of these guys
together in one family of functions like
they're different but they're not very
different what are they all cold start
to the P the Apollo knows I come in
also she
so even though this is three functions
it's not really free they're not really
different enough to warrant oh look I
know it's three different kinds they're
really just one client so I want you to
think up on your own first
how many missions or relations are going
to end up with these don't just give me
like minor differences see if you can
think of fundamentally different kinds
see how many you can think of I wonder
how many you can come up with on your
own some are easy so I've been trickier
so I'll give you a few minutes
have a think let's do it all right now
hands up if you reckon you'll want to be
who has the most honest the most
different kind and they'll give you like
over times how many do you ever been
nine Wow's it's in anyone top nine now
I'm going to wage on Ukraine if I'm
interested because I I put together my
earnest I'm I'm guessing if you had nine
or fifteen probably probably you
actually have a few that look different
but fundamentally they are the same so
let's have a look let's see if we can
compare okay
I think the first main client I'll start
with the ones that you know please tell
me you know what a rational function is
what is rational apart from sensible
coherent what does rational mean in a
mathematical context
it means a fraction because it's about a
ratio is amazing okay sign examples
what's an example okay 1 on X 1 on X
plus 1 1 1 s squared minus 1 y equals x
1 X minus 1 and on and on and on all of
these they're all rational functions
because they all have this friendship
okay I'll just very quickly it has a
domain decision I'm sorry they all have
to manage it how do you work them out
what's the most efficient way to find
out how its disputed so that the
denominator isn't it it's this guy on
the bottom that's the problem how do you
what do you do with the denominator to
find where the restrictions are okay so
you guys said that you let it equal to 0
right so I guess the flip side of that
the way I would say that use this
function can't exist when the
denominator is 0 so the denominator
cannot be zero
okay if it's anything else if for my
okay which is one for these you'll get
vertical asymptotes right there's just
that one value of x or values of X okay
just isolated sports where the function
breaks up okay fine there's my first one
next one now
hopefully you guys have this but you
probably don't remember me so please put
your hand up if you have something with
the square root ends up now does anyone
actually know what they call so these
are these are fractions but we don't
call them ratio constants or fraction
[ __ ] we actually have an adjective for
these now you sir would be because you
know what third set is also unknown but
it has an adjective which is what these
are really cool this be called radical
functions radical actually is the
adjective for the words rich okay
which is by the way it's the same place
where we get the idea of our greatness
or radians it's all the same
yes slowed it down you can put anything
underneath it's sort of radical sign
actually because if I put something like
that it's not square read anymore it's a
cubicle 32 whatever okay it's still
right now we said over here the
denominator can't be zero all right
what's the rule that's going to find the
restriction for these kinds of functions
this thing underneath the radical it has
to be greater than or equal to zero is
okay series all right you can take the
square root over 33 of zero okay but it
has to be read in that mystery now by
the way we gave this a name right what's
that thing called that thing underneath
the square root sign
I'll give you a clue what's this whole
thing called the whole thing it's called
an integral what's that pink or an
integrand this is legit we actually made
her look it up is the radicand okay uh
what do we say about it it's gonna be
great any reserve what other kinds of
functions that you have someone give me
something to have excellent okay
now example right you can pick anything
you like here the donating copy zero
here the thing underneath the radical
has to be greater than or equal to zero
what about this it's just like this
isn't it
but can you have zero you can't to
actually must be positive like you can't
have that boundary so what do you call
that thing
I'm just gonna say that number up
honestly I actually had a bit trouble
looking this up I know it's called in
general terms for all of these when you
have a function of a function you call
this inside thing the argument does that
ring a bell
so you could call that the argument but
that doesn't mean this busy with
dewclaws that's what I'm gonna call that
number or that function okay it must be
positive all right now hands up if you
have a type of family of functions that
I call relations that I haven't named
yet
hands up yeah good good let's see I
think Ted is already on the board isn't
it which one is it he's actually an
identity isn't it yes sign over cause
it's rational
nice try let's try again try again give
me another one
inverse treat does that belong in any of
these is it rational who reckons it's
rational rational implies it's some kind
of fraction right say something like
this where's the fraction a fraction
where's the fraction I'm gonna leave
this kind of the same problem here is
industry functions as we go into the
later they focus on the lead arbitrary
rules some rules that we decide right
for instance these two guys are not the
same mostly you have not looked at this
okay but they are these two lines are
not equipment they're very close but
there's a crucial difference the
difference though is one that's enclosed
by us it's a human like we just define a
difference so I'm gonna leave him off
for a minute I'm not sure if he really
fits underneath is but okay there are
restrictions but they under a different
category anyone else there's a big head
of Admissions
yes circles okay now all of a second
some of you may have said so where did
you think it was where'd you put it
I can't all right I think remains under
something here right let's let's say
what's what is a circle I'm gonna leave
this part Mike for a second okay give me
the equation of circle
is so boring okay see I had a nice crib
all right there's the units are fine
okay
now I think there's some logic here and
said this is kind of close to a radical
function isn't it it's kind of close why
why is it close
I could rewrite this Cunha yes I could
rewrite this I could say let's see let's
make why the subject so my next line
would be plus or minus the square root
okay good fine so in some ways in some
ways this is kind of a special version
of the radical function okay but it is I
think it's I think there is a difference
in to the crucial difference because
this the square root sides were
introduced by us right we had to muck
around with it right
I can be seized a little bit different I
would call these now don't forget a
funky madam I talking about domain
restrictions not range restrictions
there are related but I'm gonna call
this and this is my last category even
powers of whenever you have an even
power of y y squared 4 y 5 for 2012
right you're gonna have a restriction
because it's it is related to this one
okay when you've got an even power some
things have to be positive now better
than turning this into a radical one
here just not really right it's a
relationship you can only approximate
with two I would say it is I'm just
going to leave it there okay and I would
say therefore here they do not let it
come to zero here that thing has to be
greater than or equal to zero here
that's gotta be positive what's going on
this function this function right what's
the smallest it could possibly be zero
right
it's see it's related to this yeah
they're flip sides can you see that so
whatever this is this next one minus x
squared that's got to be greater than or
equal to zero let's see what happens
what does this thing look like one minus
x squared that's a parabola likes one
what are the intercepts minus 1 1 it's
got to be greater than or equal to 0
these values minus 1 to 1 we took sure
enough is the domain of the unit circle
okay this is a nice quick way of working
out the domain now with a circle like I
know what a circle looks like I don't
need to but in a second
we're gonna look at this guy okay we can
the natural domain